it's not about a genre or about even
sometimes specific character its if I
feel that there is an honesty and a sort
of beating heart that exists underneath
material you know so often you can say
oh well I really want to play a cop so
but that isn't really to me the reason
why for instance a movie like and watch
I gravitate towards it because not only
somebody like David Ayer who I think is
so brilliant as a writer and and as a
director but I think what really drew me
to it was the relationship and the heart
in the middle of this film you know I
mean we've seen so many cops on what
movies and you know this is different
because of that friendship and the
friendship could be taken out of that
car and put in any other context and I
think I look for that and everything I
do some sort of sense of honesty and
truth um between characters someone said
to me once that like a and I know that
being my mother being a screenwriter
she's not going to agree with me on this
but that you know great movies have been
made out of mediocre scripts and not
great movies have been made out of great
scripts you know so there is something
in that process because there is out
there is a general kind of philosophy
that you need a great script which I
agree with I totally agree with but
ultimately I think you need an energy
you need a drive and a belief and what
you're doing and that that belief
whatever that is can change an entire
film I can change anything really
for a long time I was looking for a
sense of resolution at the end of a
movie or the sense of resolution at the
end of a scene or you know feeling like
as Chris Cooper once said to me when I
was working with hymns and never having
any regrets I think that's impossible
you know in a way there is no resolve
you know the thing about making a movie
in particular and then I think actually
being on stage now it's kind of
illuminated morally on stage is the
sense that you never fully get there you
know and and it's a constantly searching
for that thing you get behaviors and
pieces and it comes together in a but
you never really do it's it's it's you
know it's um I think there are there
there are specific instances like I
remember trying to break through the
scene in this movie I did with David
Fincher's movie zodiac where it's
raining and I run up to this door and
I'm trying to get information and we
shot the scene twice and we shot it
probably over at 50 takes of it and I
remember I never really got that scene
and if I did or if he did I never did
which is an interesting thing as an
actor
education is so essential because
there's no way of knowing what good
material is we're knowing if a story is
original or knowing what makes his story
original or know how to interpret a
story or even to help if you don't have
a solid education doesn't mean you have
to go out and get it like from a common
institution but to educate yourself is
the most important thing
otherwise you'll be making blind choices
that you're not sure about through all
the beauty that is what I've looked I
can see from somebody like who I admire
so deeply someone like Paul Newman or
that your life is is everything and you
know with all of the like the lights and
all the stuff and the all-consuming
thing that is the business of making
movies you know so often you can get
sidetracked from that because it's so
enticing and amazing it's amazing people
involved but ultimately your life your
family and those things are are the
priority so if anything from somebody
like Paul Newman that's that's what um
that's what I learned
have learned so far